Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW,
OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESS.
WE'VE RAISED $200 MILLION.
WOW.
WHAT?!
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS
HEAR A GREAT IDEA...
IF THAT'S TRUE, BRING IT OVER.
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I LOVE THIS ONE.
WHOO!
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
I'D LIKE TO OFFER YOU
$400,000.
YOU'LL PARTNER WITH A BUNCH
OF DIFFERENT LABELS.
EXCUSE ME.
I WASN'T FINISHED TALKING.
I THINK I'M WORTH
TWICE AS MUCH AS BARBARA.
HE'S RIGHT.
Narrator:
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
THIS TASTES LIKE [BLEEP]
ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE ME OUT
BEHIND THE BARN NOW
AND SHOOT ME?
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE BUSINESS
EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY
IS A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE SELLING A
CHILDREN'S EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC,
SON OF AN IMMIGRANT
FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF THE WORLD'S
PREEMINENT CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
[ BIRDS CHIRPING ]
MY NAME IS CURT CAMPBELL,
AND I LIVE IN BEAUTIFUL
EGG HARBOR, WISCONSIN,
WITH MY FABULOUS WIFE, AMY JOE,
AND I'M THE OWNER
OF OILERIE USA.
AMY JOE IS THE LOVE OF MY LIFE.
WE WERE HIGH-SCHOOL SWEETHEARTS.
WE'VE BEEN MARRIED
38 AMAZING YEARS.
SHE'S MY BEST FRIEND,
MY ROCK, MY LIGHT.
IN 2003, WE WERE IN POLAND.
WE CAME ACROSS A SMALL SHOP
THAT WAS BOTTLING OLIVE OIL
RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU.
WE LOOKED AT EACH OTHER
AND SAID,
"WHY ISN'T ANYONE DOING THIS
IN AMERICA?"
WE KNEW RIGHT THEN
WE WERE ONTO SOMETHING.
HEY, SAUSAGE GUY!
AMY JOE AND I HAVE TAKEN MANY
RISKS THROUGHOUT THE YEARS,
BUT WE'RE PEOPLE
THAT NEVER GIVE UP.
WE'VE GONE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK,
AND WE SUFFERED THROUGH
SOME PRETTY HARD YEARS,
BUT WE ALWAYS LOOK
ON THE BRIGHT SIDE OF LIFE.
SUPER. THANKS FOR YOUR BUSINESS.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
I KNOW THAT THE OILERIE
CAN BECOME A HUGE
NATIONWIDE BUSINESS,
BUT I'VE TAKEN IT AS FAR
AS I CAN BY MYSELF.
AN INVESTMENT AND A PARTNERSHIP
WITH ANY OF THE SHARKS
MEANS THAT WE CAN HAVE STORES
IN EVERY MAJOR CITY IN AMERICA
AND BECOME A NATIONAL BRAND.
HI,
MY NAME IS CURT CAMPBELL,
AND I'M FROM BEAUTIFUL
EGG HARBOR, WISCONSIN.
MY COMPANY IS OILERIE USA.
I'M HERE TODAY
ASKING FOR $500,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 35%
OF MY COMPANY.
KEVIN, YOU'VE MENTIONED
THAT YOU COLLECT OLIVE OIL,
SO YOU KNOW THE NUANCES
OF FRESH OIL.
BUT MANY AMERICANS --
A LOT OF AMERICANS --
HAVE NEVER TASTED
FRESH OLIVE OIL.
NOW, BEFORE THE OILERIE
CAME ALONG,
THE ONLY WAY TO BUY OLIVE OIL
WAS TO STARE AT A SHELF
FULL OF PRETTY LABELS
AND BASICALLY POKE AND HOPE.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW IT'S GOING
TO TASTE OR IF IT'S EVEN FRESH.
THE OILERIE OLIVE-OIL-BAR SYSTEM
IS FULL OF MANY FLAVORS
OF FRESH OILS
AND AGED BALSAMIC VINEGAR
THAT ARE STORED
IN THESE EXCLUSIVE,
STAINLESS STEEL TANKS
CALLED "FUSTIS."
NOW, OUR CUSTOMERS IN AN OILERIE
STORE TASTE THE PRODUCT,
AND ONLY AFTER THEY'VE MADE
THEIR SELECTIONS
DO WE BOTTLE IT, AND WE BOTTLE
IT IN FRONT OF THEM.
AND THEY GO CRAZY OVER THE FACT
THAT THEY CAN TRY IT
BEFORE THEY BUY IT.
CURT, CAN WE TRY IT?
YOU MAY ABSOLUTELY TRY IT.
AND THERE'S A PLATE
FOR EACH OF YOU.
DO WE JUST DRINK IT?
IS THERE BREAD OR SOMETHING?
WELL, YOU'RE TASTING
AN INGREDIENT,
SO WE DON'T
CALL IT "DRINKING."
BUT IF YOU'LL JUST TIP IT,
A SMALL DROP WILL ROLL OFF
AND ONTO YOUR TONGUE.
THIS WHITE TRUFFLE --
OH, MY GOSH.
ISN'T THAT BEAUTIFUL?
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WE SELL
THAT BOTTLE OF
TRUFFLE OLIVE OIL FOR?
$16.50.
THAT BOTTLE OF TRUFFLE OIL IS
GOING TO COST ME ABOUT $3.60.
BRINGING OILS OVER
FROM ITALY IN BULK,
I'M ACTUALLY PAYING ABOUT 21
CENTS AN OUNCE FOR MY OLIVE OIL.
Cuban: WHERE DO YOU SELL THIS?
HOW DO YOU SELL IT?
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
ET CETERA.
OUR SALES LAST YEAR
WERE $3.1 MILLION.
OH.
WOW.
Greiner: WOW.
Barbara: UNBELIEVABLE.
WHO ARE YOU SELLING TO?
WELL, MY WIFE, AMY JOE, AND I --
HIGH-SCHOOL SWEETHEARTS.
WE'VE BEEN MARRIED 38 YEARS.
WE MADE A TRIP TO KRAKOW,
POLAND.
AND IN KRAKOW,
I WAS SEEING
THESE LITTLE BOUTIQUE SHOPS
THAT WERE SELLING BULK OILS,
AND THEY WOULD BOTTLE IT
IN FRONT OF YOU.
AND I'M THINKING, "THAT'S THE
COOLEST THING I'VE EVER SEEN.
WHY ISN'T ANYONE DOING THIS
IN AMERICA?"
WE CAME BACK FROM THAT TRIP,
AND WE OPENED A LITTLE, TINY
RETAIL SHOP
IN FISH CREEK, WISCONSIN --
THE FIRST OLIVE OIL STORE
IN AMERICA.
SO, CURT, TODAY THE STORE
IS A RETAIL LOCATION,
AND YOU DID $3.1 MILLION
LAST YEAR?
IN OUR FRANCHISE SYSTEM!
OH, YOU HAVE
A FRANCHISE SYSTEM?
OH.
I'M SORRY.
I AM -- I AM SORRY.
OKAY.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS,
SINCE THIS WAS
THE FIRST TIME
A SHOP LIKE THIS
EXISTED IN AMERICA,
THERE WAS AN EXTREME AMOUNT
OF INTEREST.
CUSTOMERS WERE DEMANDING
A FRANCHISE.
HOW DO WE DO THIS
ON OUR OWN?
SO WE SPENT A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF MONEY
ON LAWYERS AND CONSULTANTS
AND DEVELOPED THE OILERIE USA
FRANCHISE SYSTEM.
HOW MANY FRANCHISES
DO YOU HAVE?
WE ENDED UP WITH SEVEN.
HILTON HEAD ISLAND,
TWO IN OHIO,
MILWAUKEE, FISH CREEK,
TWO IN THE TWIN CITIES
OF MINNEAPOLIS-SAINT PAUL,
AND THEN ONE
ON THE WEST COAST --
LAKE OSWEGO, PORTLAND.
AND HOW DO THEY PAY
THE FRANCHISE FEE?
THE FRANCHISE FEE,
WHICH IS $37,500 --
TO START,
BUT WHAT'S THE ONGOING?
8% ROYALTIES.
I THINK I'VE DISTILLED
OUT OF THIS
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE,
BECAUSE I DO COLLECT
OLIVE OILS.
I'M A BUYER OF IT.
I'M PRETTY FAMILIAR
WITH THE INDUSTRY,
AND I'LL MAKE A COMMENT
ON YOUR OLIVE OIL.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH IT.
IT IS A MID- TO LOW-MARKET
OFFERING, OKAY?
HE'S AN OLIVE OIL SNOB.
IN CITIES LIKE CHICAGO
AND NEW YORK
AND DALLAS AND SAN FRANCISCO,
THERE ARE MANY, MANY OPTIONS
IN TERMS OF WHERE
SOMEONE LIKE I
CAN GO TO BUY AND INVEST
IN OLIVE OIL.
RIGHT. YES.
IN THE PLACES YOU HAVE LOCATED,
THERE'S NO OTHER OPTION TO
TASTE IT OR EVEN TO BUY IT,
IN SOME CASES.
AND THE REASON
YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
IS YOU'VE DEFAULTED
TO THOSE LOCATIONS.
THAT'S WHAT I BELIEVE.
THIS WOULD NOT WORK
IN NEW YORK CITY.
I'M BANKING ON THE FACT
THAT OUR TRADEMARK, OILERIE --
I MEAN, IF YOU WANTED
TO BUY WINE,
YOU'RE GOING TO MAYBE GO
TO A WINERY, BUT...
NOW, LOOK. I-I DON'T THINK
OILERIE IS A BIG ENOUGH
BRAND YET.
"YET."
THIS IS THE NEXT STARBUCKS.
OH, I DON'T THINK SO.
DON'T GO THERE.
I DON'T THINK.
IN FISH CREEK, WISCONSIN,
APPLE DOES $6,000 A SQUARE FOOT
RETAIL SPACE,
TIFFANY DOES $3,000.
OILERIE FISH CREEK
IS NUMBER THREE AT $2,100.
BUT, CURT, IS THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE THERE?
HOW MUCH OF THAT
IS IN THE SUMMER?
NO, I-I DO NOT WORK
IN THE STORE.
I HAD TO GET OUT OF THE STORE
THREE YEARS AGO
BECAUSE THE STRESS
WAS KILLING ME.
I'M JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND --
IS YOUR BUSINESS READY TODAY
TO SCALE?
IT IS.
'CAUSE THERE'S GOT TO BE
SOMEBODY DOING THE SALES.
THERE'S GOT TO BE SOMEBODY
DOING THE NEGOTIATIONS.
YES.
YOU'RE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP GUY.
WHO'S DOING THE OTHER PART?
THE ONLY ANSWER I HAVE
FOR YOU, ROBERT,
IS THAT'S WHY I'M HERE --
TO WORK
WITH A PERSON LIKE YOU
FOR FINANCE
AND CASH MANAGEMENT.
YOU'RE AN IMPRESSIVE GUY.
I THINK THE PRODUCT IS GREAT.
BUT YOU ALSO SAID
THAT THE STRESS BOTHERED YOU.
YOU HAD TO TAKE YOURSELF
OUT OF IT.
AND MY CONCERN IS,
WHEN I PARTNER
WITH MY ENTREPRENEURS,
I'M THERE WITH THEM,
I HELP THEM,
BUT I NEED SOMEBODY
WHO IS GOING TO REALLY BE
RUNNING THE BUSINESS
AND THE LEADER IN IT
WHILE THEY GET MY SUPPORT.
AND BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED
THAT YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE UP
TO HAVING TO DEAL WITH ALL
THE STRESS OF THAT,
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
MAY I ADDRESS THAT?
OF COURSE.
ALL RIGHT.
WHEN WE WERE DOING
THE RETAIL STORE,
THIS WAS OUR BABY.
THE RENT WAS $2,000 --
SCARED US TO DEATH
BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE $2,000.
IN OUR MARRIED LIFE,
WE'VE HAD THE PHONE
DISCONNECTED,
WE'VE HAD THE POWER
WE'VE HAD
CABLE DISCONNECTED.
I'VE BEEN THERE.
WE WOULD CLOSE
ON WEDNESDAYS,
AND I WOULD TAKE THE TRUCK
TO GREEN BAY TO THE WAREHOUSE
AND BRING BACK
SIX MORE PALLETS
SO THAT WE COULD WORK
ANOTHER WEEK.
THIS WAS THE 8-DAY-A-WEEK JOB
AND THE 90 HOURS.
NOW, I DON'T MIND DOING THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS WHAT
EVERY ENTREPRENEUR
WHO WATCHES THIS SHOW
NEEDS TO HEAR.
YEAH.
THAT, IN ORDER
TO GET TO THIS POINT,
THERE ARE TRADE-OFFS,
THERE'S STRESS.
YES.
THERE'S UPS,
AND THERE'S DOWNS.
YOU'RE EXPLAINING MORE
TO PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO BE ENTREPRENEURS
THAN WE EVER COULD.
CURT, I GET IT.
WHAT I SEE IN FRONT OF ME
IS A LOVELY, PATIENT,
HARDWORKING GENTLEMAN.
THANK YOU.
BUT IF YOU'RE GONNA BE
IN THE FRANCHISE BUSINESS,
IT IS ONE ROYAL
PAIN IN THE NECK,
AND IT'S A RUN
TO THE FINISH LINE
BEFORE THE NEXT GUY
GETS THERE.
YES.
I THINK YOU'RE NOT CUT OUT
FOR THAT.
AND SO I RELUCTANTLY SAY
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: CURT,
IT'S A GREAT BUSINESS.
YOU'VE DONE SOMETHING
VERY FEW PEOPLE EVER DO.
YOU CREATED SOMETHING
FROM NOTHING.
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO WORK
WITH YOU,
BUT THE OLIVE OIL ISN'T TALKING
MY LANGUAGE.
I'M OUT.
O'Leary: THIS IS A GREAT
BUSINESS FOR YOU.
I DON'T PERSONALLY THINK
IT'S READY TO JUMP
TO THE FRANCHISE MODEL YET.
ARE YOU GOING
TO TAKE ME OUT
BEHIND THE BARN NOW
AND SHOOT ME?
NO, I WON'T --
I WON'T SHOOT YOU, CURT.
HE'LL JUST WOUND YOU.
YOU'RE A MASTERFUL --
[ LAUGHS ]
LOOK, YOU -- YOU REALLY HUSTLED
TO CREATE SOMETHING
THAT ADDS VALUE TO
CERTAIN RETAIL LOCATIONS.
NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
YES.
BUT FOR ME, IT'S NOT INVESTABLE.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, SIR.
MARK?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT A "SHARK TANK"
GOLD DIGGER IS?
WHAT WE CALL A GOLD DIGGER
IS SOMEONE WHO COMES IN HERE
LOOKING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE EXPOSURE OF "SHARK TANK"
WITH NO INTENTION
OF EVER GETTING A DEAL.
YOU ARE THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
THANK YOU.
YOU ARE SOMEBODY WHO
IS GOING TO GET ENORMOUS
EXPOSURE, AND I'M GLAD.
YOU REALLY HAVE A NEED
FOR ONE OF US,
AND I WAS HOPING ONE OF US
WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP YOU.
AS MUCH AS IT PAINS ME,
'CAUSE I LOVE YOU...
...JUST DON'T SEE
MY BEING A PARTNER
FOR YOUR KIND OF BUSINESS.
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I UNDERSTAND,
AND I APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
THAT YOU'VE SAID TODAY,
AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT.
THANK YOU.
CURT, SAY HELLO TO AMY JOE
FOR US.
I WILL. I WILL.
THANK YOU.
WE WORKED EXTREMELY HARD
TO GET HERE,
AND THERE'S GOING
TO ALWAYS BE SETBACKS.
HI.
AND THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE TO GET UP,
DUST OURSELVES OFF,
AND KEEP DOING WHAT WE DO.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A COUPLE WITH A MODERN TAKE
ON GIFT GIVING.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS JOSH MARGULIS,
AND THIS IS
MY LOVELY WIFE, SARA.
WE ARE FROM SEBASTOPOL,
CALIFORNIA,
AND THE BEAUTIFUL
SONOMA WINE COUNTRY,
AND WE'RE THE FOUNDERS
OF HONEYFUND,
THE FREE HONEYMOON
GIFT REGISTRY.
WE'RE SEEKING $400,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
HONEYFUND IS A UNIQUE
WEDDING-GIFT REGISTRY
WHERE COUPLES CAN RAISE FUNDS
TOWARD THEIR DREAM HONEYMOON
AS A WEDDING GIFT,
A HONEYMOON THEY MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO AFFORD.
AND THEIR WEDDING GUESTS
ARE FREE FROM SHOPPING
AT THE SAME OLD
DEPARTMENT STORES
FOR THE SAME BORING
WEDDING GIFTS.
INSTEAD, THEY GET TO GIVE
SOMETHING WAY MORE EXCITING --
A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME
HONEYMOON.
WOULD YOU RATHER GIVE SOMEONE
A BLENDER
OR A NIGHT
IN A BEACH BUNGALOW?
INSTEAD OF A SET OF CHINA,
HOW ABOUT A TRIP TO CHINA?
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
COUPLES CREATE
A HONEYFUND PAGE
LISTING ALL THE FUN ASPECTS
OF THEIR HONEYMOON,
THINGS LIKE A COUPLE'S MASSAGE
OR SCUBA DIVING.
WEDDING GUESTS
VISIT THE PAGE
AND MAKE A CHOICE
FROM THE REGISTRY,
AND THE GIFT FUNDS
ARE PAID
DIRECTLY TO THE COUPLE'S
PAYMENT ACCOUNT.
WE CALL THIS PROCESS
"CROWD-GIFTING" --
CROWDFUNDING FOR GIFTS.
SO, RIGHT NOW WE'D LIKE
TO GET YOU GUYS
IN THE HONEYMOON SPIRIT.
OH.
Herjavec: OH!
ALOHA.
ALOHA, MR. HERJAVEC.
[ CHUCKLES ]
THANK YOU.
Greiner: THANK YOU.
HI, MR. O'LEARY.
WHAT'S IN THIS?
PLEASE,
CALL ME MR. WONDERFUL.
OKAY, MR. WONDERFUL.
THIS HAS BEEN
A WONDERFUL HONEYMOON WITH YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
CHEERS, MARK.
SO NOW WE'D LIKE
TO PROPOSE A TOAST
AND INVITE YOU TO JOIN US
AS WE CONTINUE TO PIONEER
THE MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR
CROWD-GIFTING MARKET.
TO CASH FLOW.
Sara: CHEERS.
CHEERS.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN
IN BUSINESS,
AND WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
JOSH CREATED A SIMPLE PAGE
ON OUR OWN WEDDING WEBSITE.
THIS WAS 10 YEARS AGO,
AND OUR WEDDING GUESTS
CONTRIBUTED
MORE THAN $5,000
TO OUR HONEYMOON.
WOW.
JOSH AND I WERE ASPIRING
ENTREPRENEURS AT THE TIME.
WE KNEW THAT,
WHEN WE GOT MARRIED,
WE WERE GOING TO START
OUR OWN VENTURE SOMEDAY.
AND JUST FROM THE REACTION
OF OUR WEDDING GUESTS,
WE KNEW THIS WAS
OUR BUSINESS.
WE'VE HELPED HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF COUPLES
THROUGH OUR SITE,
AND TO DATE,
WE'VE RAISED FOR OUR COUPLES
$200 MILLION.
WHOA.
WOW.
Corcoran:
YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING.
THAT'S RIGHT.
HOW DO YOU MAKE MONEY?
WE -- WE -- WE HAVE A DEAL
WITH -- WITH PAYPAL.
THE MONEY THAT COMES
FROM GUESTS
GOES DIRECTLY
TO THEIR PAYPAL ACCOUNT,
AND WE'RE TAKING
A SMALL FEE
BECAUSE WE HAVE
SUCH LARGE VOLUME.
WHAT WERE THE SALES LAST YEAR?
IT WAS $67 MILLION?
FOR THE TRANSACTION
VOLUME.
YES.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE ON THAT?
SO, LAST YEAR,
OUR REVENUE WAS $900,870.
SO ON THAT MILLION,
WHAT DO YOU MAKE ON IT?
AFTER ALL OVERHEAD
AND SALARIES,
WE PROFITED
$217,000 LAST YEAR.
SO THIS ALL ABOUT
CUSTOMER ACQUISITION COSTS
AND THEIR VALUE.
YES.
SO GIVE US THOSE NUMBERS.
EVERY COUPLE THAT SIGNS UP
AND PUBLISHES A REGISTRY
INVITES, ON AVERAGE,
150 WEDDING GUESTS
TO COME AND LOOK AT IT.
VERY CLEVER, ACTUALLY.
BUT ON AVERAGE, WE PAY 88 CENTS
TO ACQUIRE A CUSTOMER.
AND WHAT'S THE VALUE?
AND WE GET $9 OUT OF
EVERY CUSTOMER ON AVERAGE.
THAT'S THE AVERAGE VALUE?
YEAH.
GUYS, I GET THAT
AS, YOU KNOW,
A PERSONAL BUSINESS, PUTTING
$500,000, ESSENTIALLY,
IN THE BANK FOR YOURSELVES
AS A COUPLE IS PHENOMENAL.
BUT THERE'S A "BUT" COMING.
YEAH, 'CAUSE IT DOESN'T
MAKE IT INVESTABLE.
RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT TO TELL US
WHERE YOU'RE GOING FROM THERE
'CAUSE, TO BE HONEST,
TO BE IN BUSINESS 10 YEARS
AND TO DO $987,000 IN
GROSS REVENUE IS HORRIBLE.
OKAY, YEAH.
IT'S -- IT'S BEEN A LIFESTYLE
BUSINESS UP TO THIS POINT.
AND OF COURSE WE'RE HERE
BECAUSE THERE'S MORE.
"BUT WAIT!"
BUT WAIT.
THERE'S MORE.
SO, PEOPLE HAVE USED
THIS SITE, HONEYFUND,
FOR THINGS
OTHER THAN WEDDINGS.
Sara:
SO WE CREATED PLUMFUND.
ANYONE CAN RAISE MONEY
FOR ANYTHING WITH THIS SITE.
THIS WOMAN'S
HAVING A BIRTHDAY.
WE HAD A WOMAN THAT GRADUATED
WITH HER MASTER'S DEGREE.
Herjavec: SARA, HANG ON.
YOUR ANSWER
TO SCALING HONEYFUND
IS TO DO ANOTHER FUND.
OUR ANSWER IS TO DO
A WHOLE PORTFOLIO OF FUNDS.
UGH.
ARE THESE UP AND RUNNING?
PLUMFUND AND HONEYFUND
ARE RUNNING.
THESE ARE PLANNED.
OKAY, GIVE US THE METRICS
ON PLUMFUND.
WHEN DID IT START,
WHAT ARE THE REVENUES NOW?
WE'VE GENERATED $400,000
WITH PLUMFUND
AND ABOUT $10,000
IN REVENUE.
HOW MANY MONTHS?
UH, FOR ABOUT 12 MONTHS.
Herjavec: I THINK
IT'S A FANTASTIC IDEA,
BUT YOU --
YOU'RE NOT SELLING ME.
I'VE GOT ANOTHER IDEA
FOR YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
FONDODEMIEL -- THAT IS SPANISH
FOR "HONEYFUND."
THERE ARE 53 MILLION SPANISH
SPEAKERS IN THE U.S. ALONE.
THIS COULD DOUBLE OUR BUSINESS
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
YOU TOLD ME $217,000 AFTER YOU
PAID YOURSELF, PRE-TAX.
YES.
THAT'S $150,000 AFTER TAX OF
FREE CASH THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
YEAH. MM-HMM.
FOR THE VALUE ON IT
OF $4 MILLION.
MM-HMM.
YOU WANT ME TO PAY 26 TIMES
YOUR FREE CASH FLOW
TO BUY EQUITY
IN YOUR COMPANY.
WE ARE -- THANK YOU FOR ASKING
ABOUT THE VALUATION.
IT'S BASED ON PROJECTIONS
FOR 2015.
SO YOU'RE GOING
TO GROW BY 350%?
HOW YOU GONNA DO THAT?
BY ADDING THE OTHER LIFE EVENTS
AND SPANISH.
OH! SO THAT'S THE RISK
I HAVE TO TAKE --
THAT YOUR CUSTOMER
ACQUISITION COSTS
WILL BE THE SAME FOR THAT
AS THEY WERE ON THIS.
THEY'LL BE SOMEWHAT HIGHER,
BUT THEY COME DOWN OVER TIME,
IN OUR EXPERIENCE.
YOU KNOW, I LOVE THE IDEA OF YOU
TAKING IT TO OTHER COUNTRIES --
DOING IT IN SPANISH.
YOU'RE JUST EXPANDING IT.
I THINK
THAT'S REALLY SMART.
BUT I THINK CROWDFUNDING
IS CROWDED.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME,
LORI.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU GET FUNDED TODAY,
HOW WOULD I GET
MY $400,000 BACK?
SO, WHAT WE'RE
PLANNING TO DO
IS SCALE THE BUSINESS QUICKLY
OVER FIVE YEARS,
REALLY DOMINATE
THE CROWD-GIFTING SPACE.
GUYS, JUST -- JUST WHAT
YOU SAID RIGHT THERE
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS SCALING
QUICKLY OVER FIVE YEARS.
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE THIS
A TECHNOLOGY COMPANY,
AND BY SAYING
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT ALL THESE OTHER OPTIONS,
YOU'RE TELLING ME
YOU DON'T HAVE A SOLUTION
TO GO OUT AND DOMINATE JUST
WHAT YOU ALREADY SUPPOSEDLY
ARE DOMINATING IN.
WE ALREADY DO DOMINATE
THIS MARKET.
Cuban: THEN --
WE HAVE 30% MARKET SHARE
IN THIS SPACE.
YOU'VE GOT A NICE, LITTLE
BUSINESS, LIKE I SAID.
BRAVO. RIGHT?
BUT WHEN A BUSINESS
GETS TO A POINT
WHERE YOU HAVE TO START LOOKING
EVERYWHERE ELSE,
IT SUGGEST TO ME
THAT IT'S ON AUTOPILOT.
IF IT WAS GROWING SO FAST
AND IT WAS SO PROFITABLE,
THEN YOU'D BE TELLING US,
"WE NEED THIS CAPITAL
JUST TO KEEP UP WITH IT."
AND THAT'S NOT
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: OKAY, SARA, HERE --
HERE'S WHERE I'M AT.
IN MY WORLD, THERE'S TWO TYPES
OF COMPANIES --
THE QUICK AND THE DEAD.
ALL RIGHT?
YOU'RE APPROACHING
YOUR CORE VALUE
AND TRYING TO MONETIZE IT
THE WRONG WAY.
HMM.
I CAN HELP YOU.
I THINK YOU'VE DONE
A PHENOMENAL JOB
OF CREATING TRANSACTION VALUE.
THAT'S WHERE YOU GOT TO GO TO,
NOT THE BRAND EXTENSION.
OKAY.
HERE'S MY OFFER, SARA.
I'LL GIVE YOU -- YOU'RE ASKING
FOR $400,000.
I'LL GIVE YOU $500,000...
AND THE PLOT THICKENS.
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT,
AND ROBERT HAS OFFERED
THE ONLINE GIFTING
REGISTRY HONEYFUND
$100,000 MORE
THAN THEY WERE SEEKING.
BUT HOW MUCH EQUITY
WILL HE WANT?
I'LL GIVE YOU --
YOU'RE ASKING FOR $400,000?
I'LL GIVE YOU $500,000...
...FOR 50%.
THANK YOU.
SO A $1 MILLION VALUATION.
$1 MILLION VALUATION.
IT'S FOUR TIMES WHAT YOU EARNED
LAST YEAR.
BECAUSE OF THE DIRECTIONS
YOU WANT TO GO,
I GOT TO BE AN EQUAL PARTNER.
HMM.
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
THOSE ARGUMENTS WITH YOU
ABOUT YOU WANT TO GO THIS WAY,
I WANT TO GO THAT WAY.
WE GOT TO BE
ON THE SAME PAGE.
IF YOU WANT TO DOMINATE
THIS SPACE, I'M YOUR GUY.
AND THE PLOT THICKENS.
O'Leary: OKAY.
SURE DOES.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER
THAT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $400,000.
I DON'T WANT ANY EQUITY.
I WANT 1/3 OF
YOUR TRANSACTIONAL REVENUE
UNTIL I GET THREE TIMES BACK
ON MY $400,000.
THAT MEANS YOU HAVE TO PAY ME
BACK $1.2 MILLION.
AND HERE'S THE GOOD PART.
AFTER THAT, I'M GONE.
YOU GIVE UP NOTHING.
AND WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO
FOR THEM?
I'M GOING TO FUND THEM.
THAT'S IT.
YOU'VE MET A BANKER HERE TODAY.
YEP.
I AM FUNDING YOUR GROWTH
FOR YOU
AND GETTING A PRETTY DECENT
RETURN FOR DOING IT,
BUT NO EQUITY.
IF YOU HIT IT OUT OF THE PARK,
IT'S ALL YOURS.
I GOT IT.
Cuban: HE'S RIGHT.
HE'S RIGHT. I'VE NEVER, EVER,
EVER IN MY ENTIRE LIFE
SAID, "MR. WONDERFUL OFFERED
A GOOD DEAL."
Sara: I HAVE NEVER HEARD A DEAL
FROM HIM LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING?
YOU'RE DOING
A PHONY ROYALTY DEAL
DISGUISED AS SOMETHING ELSE.
NO, HE'S NOT. NO, HE'S NOT.
NO, HE'S NOT.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
IF YOU HAVE SOMETHING BETTER --
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY CREATIVITY,
BARBARA.
JOSH, THE ONLY THING
HE CARES ABOUT
IN HIS OFFER
IS GETTING HIS MONEY BACK.
OF COURSE.
WHICH IS FINE.
AND SO DO YOU.
WHO DOESN'T?
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
HANG ON A SECOND.
WHAT I CARE ABOUT IS GROWING
THE BUSINESS FUNDAMENTALLY.
I WOULD PREFER THAT YOU FOCUS
ON GETTING BACK MORE OF THAT
70% SHARE YOU DON'T HAVE,
AND I WOULD WORK TOWARDS THAT,
BECAUSE IT WOULD COMPRESS
THE TIME I'M WAITING
TO GET MY $1.2 MILLION BACK.
Sara: YES.
I CAN TELL YOU UNEQUIVOCALLY
IT'S A BAD IDEA.
I DON'T LEND MONEY
TO SMALL BUSINESSES
AND TRY TO GET IT BACK
AT ANY COST.
I INVEST IN COMPANIES
TO GROW THEM QUICKLY.
BARB, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I LOVE THE TWO OF YOU.
YOU'RE ROCK SOLID.
YOU COULDN'T BE BETTER PARTNERS.
HERE'S MY OFFER.
$400,000 FOR 30%.
SARA, I'LL MATCH
BARBARA'S OFFER.
SO, WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO?
SO, ROBERT,
WE WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN DOING A DEAL WITH YOU
IF YOU WOULD BE WILLING
TO GO DOWN TO 25%.
Herjavec:
THAT'S RIDICULOUS, JOSH.
YOU'RE GONNA NEGOTIATE WITH ME
ON A 5% DEAL?
WE DON'T WANT TO START
THAT WAY.
I'M STICKING AT $400,000
AT 30%.
[ WHISPERING INDISTINCTLY ]
MR. O'LEARY,
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
WHOA.
WOW.
WHAT A SURPRISE.
I THINK YOU MADE
A WISE DECISION.
WOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
O'Leary:
THAT'S GOOD DISCIPLINE.
Sara: THANK YOU.
CONGRATS, GUYS.
WHOO-HOO!
I THINK WE JUST GOT THE
BEST DEAL OUT OF MR. O'LEARY
THAT ANYONE'S EVER GOT
OUT OF THE SHARK TANK.
I THINK SO.
KEVIN, I THINK YOU --
YOU WAKE UP AT NIGHT
IN YOUR CRIB,
AND YOU SAY, "WHAT DEALS
CAN I COME UP WITH TODAY?"
ROBERT,
YOU HAVE NO CREATIVITY.
YOU -- YOU SHARKS HAVE
NO CREATIVITY WHATSOEVER.
I'M SENDING YOU AN INVOICE
JUST BECAUSE YOU'VE LEARNED
SOMETHING TODAY.
Cuban:
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
Narrator: IN SEASON 5,
WE SAW CHARLES MICHAEL YIM
MAKE A DEAL
WITH ALL FIVES SHARKS
FOR HIS INNOVATIVE SMARTPHONE
BREATHALYZER, BREATHOMETER.
PLUG IT INTO A SMARTPHONE.
WITHIN SECONDS,
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO KNOW WHAT
YOUR BREATH-ALCOHOL LEVEL IS.
$1 MILLION FOR 30%.
I ACCEPT.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
I CAME BY THE TANK TODAY
BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO GET ALL
FIVE SHARKS IN THE SAME ROOM.
HEY, LOOK AT THIS GUY.
HEY, GUYS.
AND I PERSONALLY WANTED
TO DROP BY
TO SHOW THEM BREEZE,
OUR NEWEST PRODUCT.
THIS IS BLUETOOTH.
IT'S WIRELESS.
SO IF I CLICK THIS BUTTON
ON THE BACK,
IT'LL PAIR WITHIN SECONDS.
OH, WOW.
BREEZE IS THE MOST ADVANCED
SMARTPHONE BREATHALYZER
IN THE WORLD.
IT'S WIRELESS,
AND IT HAS
A STATE-OF-THE-ART SENSOR
WHICH ALLOWS IT TO HAVE
REAL-TIME RESULTS.
THIS REALLY
TURNED OUT NICELY.
WE ALWAYS LOVE
TO HEAR GREAT NEWS.
NOW GET BACK TO WORK.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE FORMED A PARTNERSHIP
WITH CLEVELAND CLINIC,
WHICH IS THE NUMBER-ONE BREATH
ANALYSIS LAB IN THE WORLD.
TOGETHER, WE'LL BUILD PRODUCTS
THAT WILL REVOLUTIONIZE
THE BREATH-ANALYSIS SPACE.
IT'S PERFECT.
UP UNTIL NOW, WE'VE BEEN
PREDOMINANTLY ONLINE,
BUT WE'RE ABOUT
TO ROLL OUT NATIONWIDE.
BECAUSE OF THE HELP
OF THE SHARKS,
WE'RE GONNA BE AVAILABLE
AT BEST BUY AND BROOKSTONE.
THERE IT IS.
OH, THERE IT IS.
ON MY LAST UPDATE
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO,
I REPORTED A LITTLE
OVER $1 MILLION IN SALES.
NOW, JUST A YEAR AFTER AIRING,
WE HAVE CLOSE TO $10 MILLION
IN SALES.
GOOD JOB.
AWESOME.
I FEEL LIKE I'M LIVING
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
POWER OF "SHARK TANK"
BRINGING SOMETHING
THAT WAS JUST IN MY GARAGE
TO STORE SHELVES TODAY --
IT'S LIKE A DREAM COME TRUE.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS AN INNOVATION
IN THE PERSONAL SECURITY
BUSINESS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS PHIL REITNOUR
FROM MELVIN, PENNSYLVANIA,
AND I'M THE FOUNDER
OF EmergenSee.
AND I'M JASON FRIEDBERG,
A RETIRED POLICE CHIEF,
ALSO FROM PENNSYLVANIA.
WE ARE SEEKING $250,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10%
OF OUR BUSINESS.
EmergenSee IS AN AMAZING
NEW MOBILE TECHNOLOGY
THAT TURNS YOUR SMARTPHONE
OR TABLET
INTO A PERSONAL
SECURITY SYSTEM.
THIS STREAMS LIVE VIDEO,
AUDIO, GPS, LOCATION,
AND MOVEMENTS TO GET THE HELP
YOU NEED IMMEDIATELY,
ALL WITH A TAP
OF THE APP.
SHARKS, EACH YEAR,
OVER 237 MILLION
EMERGENCY CALLS ARE MADE
TO 911 CENTERS
IN THE UNITED STATES ALONE.
70% OF THOSE CALLS ARE MADE
FROM MOBILE DEVICES.
UNFORTUNATELY,
NOT ALL 911 CENTERS
CAN RECEIVE GPS LOCATION
INFORMATION,
AND ONLY A HANDFUL CAN RECEIVE
TEXT MESSAGES,
AND NONE CAN RECEIVE VIDEO --
UNTIL NOW.
EmergenSee IS
THE PERFECT SOLUTION.
PLEASE TAKE A LOOK.
Woman: THE EmergenSee APP
TURNS YOUR SMARTPHONE
INTO YOUR OWN
PERSONAL SECURITY SYSTEM
THAT INSTANTLY CONNECTS YOU TO
FAMILY, FRIENDS, AND AUTHORITIES
DURING AN EMERGENCY.
IF YOU'RE WALKING ALONE AT NIGHT
AND FEEL UNSAFE OR THREATENED,
JUST TAP THE EmergenSee APP
AND YOUR PERSONAL SECURITY
SYSTEM ENGAGES.
EmergenSee INSTANTLY TRANSMITS
STREAMING LIVE VIDEO,
LIVE AUDIO, PINPOINTS YOUR EXACT
LOCATION ON A GEO-MAP,
AND ALL THIS IS SENT DIRECTLY
TO YOUR DESIGNATED EMERGENCY
CONTACTS AND RESPONDERS.
HELP IS JUST A SINGLE TAP AWAY
WITH THE FREE DOWNLOAD
OF EmergenSee.
SHARKS, EmergenSee
IS CURRENTLY PROVIDING
THIS STATE-OF-THE-ART
SECURITY TECHNOLOGY
TO NUMEROUS INDIVIDUALS
AND BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
AND AROUND THE WORLD.
SO, WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS
WOULD LOVE TO EMERGE WITH US
AND SEE YOUR
INVESTMENT GROW?
SO, HOW'S IT ALL CONFIGURED?
YOU DOWNLOAD THE APP,
AND YOU PUT
ALL YOUR INFORMATION IN,
AND IT GOES DIRECTLY TO OUR
BACK END 911 MONITORING CENTER.
YOU HAVE A -- YOU BUILT
A BACK END INTERFACE
TO THE EXISTING 911 SYSTEM?
WE -- ACTUALLY, TO OUR OWN
PRIVATE MONITORING CENTER.
SO YOU DO IT LIKE
A SECURITY FIRM, BASICALLY.
CORRECT.
JASON, WHEN THAT PERSON
IN YOUR CENTER
IS GETTING THE INFORMATION,
WHAT DO THEY GAIN?
THEY GET AUDIO, VIDEO,
GPS TRACKING,
THE ABILITY TO TEXT AND HAVE
A CONVERSATION IMMEDIATELY.
IN YOUR OWN EXAMPLE,
THAT GIRL IS WALKING,
SHE'S GOT THE PHONE
IN HER HAND.
SURE. CORRECT.
SHE TAPS THE BUTTON.
YEP.
SHE'S WORRIED THERE'S SOMEBODY
BEHIND HER.
CORRECT.
SHE'S NOT GONNA TAKE THAT PHONE,
TURN AROUND, AND GO LIKE THAT.
WE'RE NOT ASKING HER TO.
WHAT WE HOPE TO DO
IN A SITUATION LIKE THAT
IS THEY ACTUALLY START TO ROLL
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT,
FIRE, AND EMS
IF THEY FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE.
BUT I DON'T GET WHY THAT'S
AN ADVANTAGE IN ANY WAY.
LIKE, SAY, FOR EXAMPLE --
WHY WOULDN'T I SPEED DIAL 911
AND FEEL JUST AS --
WELL, 911
VERSUS TAPPING THAT --
OR SPEED DIAL 911.
Greiner:
WELL, ONE VERSUS THREE.
WELL, AND -- AND THE REAL ISSUE
WITH DIALING THE 911 IS
ALL THEY'RE GONNA GET
IS MUFFLED NOISES.
WITH A VIDEO, IT ADDS
A COMPLETELY NEW DIMENSION.
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE USING IT?
UH...
211,000.
DO YOU CHARGE THEM
TO DOWNLOAD IT?
IT'S A FREE DOWNLOAD
WITH THE ABILITY TO UPGRADE
FOR A MONTHLY SERVICE.
WITH THE FREE VERSION,
THERE'S NO MONTHLY MONITORING.
IT'S SENT TO FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
IT DOESN'T GO TO THE POLICE.
BUT YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR IT.
CORRECT --
THE FREE VERSION.
THE PAID VERSION --
DO YOU HAVE 211,000
PREMIUM SUBSCRIBERS?
NO.
YOU HAVE 211,000 DOWNLOADS.
CORRECT.
DING, DING, DING, DING, DING,
DING, DING!
JUST LET ME SAY THAT, AS FAR
AS THE PREMIUM CUSTOMER GOES --
THE MONTHLY SUBSCRIBERS --
THAT WAS ONLY ROLLED OUT
A MONTH AGO.
OF THE 211,000,
HOW MANY WENT
FOR THE PREMIUM SERVICE?
WELL, WE JUST STARED
A MONTH AGO.
I THINK THERE'S LIKE 138.
HOW MUCH ARE THEY PAYING
A MONTH?
$8.99 A MONTH.
BUT OVER
THE PAST SIX MONTHS,
WE'VE SIGNED UP NUMEROUS
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
WE HAVE, UH, SOME ENTERPRISES,
BUSINESSES, WE SIGNED UP.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
TELL ME ABOUT
THE ENTERPRISE VERSION. JUST --
WE COME TO YOUR COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY
OR CORPORATION
AND WE INSTALL IT.
WE SET UP A GEO-FENCE
AT YOUR LOCATION.
ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS
WITHIN THAT GEO-FENCE
GOES RIGHT TO YOUR PUBLIC SAFETY
OR SECURITY DEPARTMENT.
AND GEOFENCE MEANS THAT
YOU CAN RECOGNIZE ANYTHING
INSIDE THAT PERIMETER?
CORRECT.
SO, LORI'S AT COLLEGE,
AND THAT UNIVERSITY
OR COLLEGE
IS PART OF
YOUR ENTERPRISE PROGRAM.
RIGHT.
SO SHE PUSHES THE BUTTON.
TELL ME WHAT HAPPENS.
IF THEY HIT IT AND THEY'RE
ON THE COLLEGE CAMPUS,
IT GOES RIGHT BACK TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY DEPARTMENT.
ARE THEY PAYING YOU
FOR THIS?
AVERAGE INSTALLATION
FOR A COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY
IS ABOUT $25,000 TO START.
$25,000 ANNUALLY?
YES, ANNUALLY.
SO THAT'S A LITTLE BUSINESS.
NOW WE'RE TALKING!
OKAY, SO WHAT'S
YOUR TOTAL SALES?
$180 -- $185,000.
OF THE $185,000,
WHAT WAS YOUR PROFIT?
THERE'S NO PROFIT
AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA BE
PROFITABLE AROUND OCTOBER.
Greiner:
BUT WHAT DID YOU LOSE?
HOW MUCH DID YOU
PUT IN YOURSELF?
I PUT IN OVER $3 MILLION.
Both: $3 MILLION?
OOH.
Corcoran: OH, MY GOD.
WHERE DID YOU GET
THAT MONEY FROM?
I WAS IN BANKING, OIL,
REAL ESTATE.
SOLD ALL THOSE OFF.
WHO -- WHO'S YOUR TECH --
WHO'S YOUR MAIN GEEK?
MAIN GEEK IS A GUY NAMED --
IS A GUY NAMED JEAN.
IT'S A GREAT COMPANY
THAT WE HAVE WORKING WITH US.
SO YOU CAME UP WITH THE IDEA,
RIGHT?
Reitnour: YES.
YOU THOUGHT
IT WAS A GREAT IDEA.
AND THEN YOU OUTSOURCED IT
TO THESE GUYS,
WHO CHARGED YOU HOW MUCH?
WE STARTED FIRST WITH A GUY
WHO WAS A DIRECTOR, UH,
OF TECHNOLOGY AT APPLE.
HE PUT ME IN TOUCH
WITH SOMEBODY ELSE.
YOU REALIZED THAT WAS A
SUPER-COMPETITIVE BUSINESS,
RIGHT, THAT WAS GONNA BE
VERY DIFFICULT?
YEP, THAT'S CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT.
SO YOU SAID, "I NEED
SOME MORE BRAIN POWER
"TO MAKE IT MORE --
MORE ADVANCED
SO THAT I CAN
DIFFERENTIATE MYSELF."
RIGHT.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU PAID THEM
TO DEVELOP THE TECHNOLOGY?
THE FIRST SECTION
OF THE DEVELOPMENT
FOR THE TECHNOLOGY
WAS ABOUT 500 GRAND,
AND THEN I'D SAY THE NEXT PART
WAS, YOU KNOW, $750,000,
AND THEN THE LAST PART
WAS ABOUT $750,000.
WHOA.
THEY SAW YOU COMING, BRO.
YEAH.
YOU PUT $3 MILLION IN.
WHAT'S LEFT IN THE BANK?
ROUGHLY,
THERE'S $68,000 IN THE BANK.
WOW!
LOOK, YOU -- YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH A PROBLEM
THAT EVERY ENTREPRENEUR
WHO'S NON-TECHNICAL DEALS WITH
TRYING TO CREATE A COMPANY
THAT'S BUILT ON TECHNOLOGY,
RIGHT?
THE ONE CONSTANT IN ANY
TECHNOLOGY-BASED COMPANY
IS WHAT?
CHANGE.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE TECHNOLOGY
INSIDE AND OUT
TO BE ABLE TO ANTICIPATE
WHERE THINGS ARE GOING.
THAT'S NOT YOU.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I TOTALLY TRUSTED YOU GUYS.
YOU'RE GREAT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE GONNA MAKE IT.
I JUST DON'T HAVE THE FAITH
THAT THIS BUSINESS WILL WORK.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
I KNOW THERE'S A SENSE
OF CONCERN
BECAUSE YOU'VE SHOWN ME
A VALUATION
OF $2.5 MILLION
WHEN YOURS IS OVER $3 MILLION.
SO YOU'RE TELLING ME,
AS AN INVESTOR,
YOU'RE WILLING TO TAKE DILUTION
IF I DEPLOY MY CAPITAL.
YEAH, HE'S IN SO DEEP,
YOUR PANT LEGS ARE ROLLED UP
RIGHT NOW. I MEAN...
WHAT IT HAS TO BE --
PHIL, THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
Reitnour: YEAH. RIGHT.
THEY SPEAK TO ME.
I'M A CASH WHISPERER.
SO, YOU KNOW,
I WISH YOU GUYS LUCK,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA BE PART
OF THIS JOURNEY.
I'M OUT.
I LIKE THE CONCEPT.
I THINK ANYTHING THAT KEEPS
PEOPLE SAFER IS A GREAT THING.
MM-HMM.
BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT
IT'S BEING EXECUTED PROPERLY
OR NOT AT THIS POINT.
SURE.
AND FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT I THINK THE MISTAKE
YOU'VE MADE
UP UNTIL THIS POINT.
OKAY.
YOU STARTED
WITH TOO MUCH MONEY.
YEP.
OKAY.
SO, I WENT BACK TO WORK
NINE YEARS AGO.
I WAS A STAY-AT-HOME DAD.
AND I WAS GONNA CONQUER
THE WORLD OF SECURITY,
SO I OPENED UP
THE BUSINESS.
WE STARTED WITH MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS,
'CAUSE I KNEW EVERYTHING,
RIGHT?
RIGHT.
OUR FORECAST WAS $5 MILLION
IN SALES.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE SOLD?
$400,000.
WE LOST $1 MILLION.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I SAID?
"THAT'S OKAY.
LET ME PUT ANOTHER
$1 MILLION IN."
THAT'S THE CURSE
OF SUCCESS.
YOU GET ARROGANT THINKING
EVERYTHING YOU DO IS SMART.
YEAH,
'CAUSE I KNOW EVERYTHING.
THE BEAUTY OF NOT HAVING
A LOT OF MONEY
IS YOU TRY SOMETHING,
AND THEN YOU CHANGE.
AND AS MARK SAID,
NEITHER OF YOU ARE A GEEK.
IF YOU'RE
A TECHNOLOGY COMPANY,
YOU GOT TO HAVE
TECHNOLOGY BRAIN TRUST
IN A LEADERSHIP POSITION.
YOU GUYS ARE NOT THE TWO GUYS
TO EXECUTE THIS STRATEGY.
O'Leary: WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
ROBERT?
I'M OUT.
WELL...
I THINK THAT'S IT, GUYS.
THANK YOU ALL.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME
AND ATTENTION. APPRECIATE IT.
THEY SEE
THE TECHNOLOGY PITFALLS
AND THE THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO IMPROVE UPON
TO MAKE IT A VIABLE PRODUCT,
AND I THINK THAT ADVICE,
IN AND OF ITSELF,
IS GONNA BE A HUGE SUCCESS
FOR US.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
LET'S DO THIS.
DO IT!
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
ARE YOUNG ENTREPRENEURS
WITH A BEVERAGE
FOR A NEW GENERATION.
HEY, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S JUSTIN FENCHEL.
I'M BRAD SCHULTZ.
AND I'M AIMY STEADMAN,
AND WE'RE FROM AUSTIN, TEXAS.
OUR COMPANY IS
BeatBox BEVERAGES,
AND WE'RE SEEKING $200,000
FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
NOW, KEVIN, YOU KNOW WINE.
SO PICTURE THIS --
A DELIGHTFUL CABERNET
FROM THE BORDEAUX REGION
OF FRANCE.
IT'S BEEN AGED IN OAK BARRELS
FOR 15 YEARS.
IT'S PERFECT.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU CAN ALMOST TASTE IT,
RIGHT?
IF THAT'S TRUE, BRING IT OVER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL,
THERE'S JUST ONE PROBLEM.
WHAT?
Together: BORING!
EXACTLY!
[ LAUGHS ]
Corcoran:
NOW WE'RE GETTING DOWN.
OH.
THIS IS BeatBox BEVERAGES,
AND WE ARE NOT BORING.
WE'RE CHANGING BOX WINE FOREVER
WITH FLAVORS LIKE
CRANBERRY LIMEADE
AND BLUE-RASPBERRY LEMONADE,
ALL IN ONE
SWEET-LOOKING BeatBox.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST A BOX.
IT'S AN EXPERIENCE.
OOH.
TAKE BeatBox
TO YOUR NEXT PARTY,
AND YOU'RE INSTANTLY
A LEGEND.
[ LAUGHS ]
Steadman: BOXED WINE
IS INCREDIBLY POPULAR.
IT'S AFFORDABLE,
IT'S CONVENIENT,
IT'S GOT A LARGE SIZE
WHERE YOU CAN SHARE
WITH EVERYONE AT THE PARTY.
BUT THE WINE YOU FIND INSIDE
LEAVES MUCH TO BE DESIRED.
WE'RE USING
A UNIQUE ORANGE WINE
THAT DRINKS MORE LIKE A SPIRIT
THAN A WINE
AND ALLOWS US
TO CREATE MIXED DRINKS
THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
ABSOLUTELY LOVE.
BeatBox IS A PARTY IN A BOX,
WITH ALMOST SEVEN BOTTLES OF
WINE PACKED INTO EVERY BOX.
WOW.
WE CREATED AN INNOVATIVE,
FUN BRAND
THAT'S REALLY SPEAKING
TO OUR GENERATION,
AND WE'RE READY TO TAKE THIS
COMPANY TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
THE ONLY QUESTION IS,
WILL THE SHARKS BE JOINING
THE BeatBox PARTY?
LET'S TRY SOME!
YEAH!
WHAT IS ORANGE WINE?
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF THAT.
YEAH, SO, ORANGE WINE IS A --
IS A UNIQUE WINE.
IT'S ACTUALLY, UH, CLEAR,
MUCH MORE LIKE A WHITE SPIRIT.
THE BLUE ONE IS THE
BLUE-RASPBERRY LEMONADE.
THE PINK IS
A CRANBERRY LIMEADE.
THE YELLOW-ISH COLOR
IS OUR MARGARITA FLAVOR.
AND THE TEA IS A SWEET TEA.
THIS TASTES LIKE [BLEEP]
OH, ARE YOU KIDDING?
THIS IS GOOD.
HE LOVES IT!
Man: YEAH!
THIS IS DELICIOUS.
HE'S CRAZY.
IT'S A PARTY.
I LOVE THIS ONE.
REMINDS ME OFF THOSE, LIKE
BLUE-RASPBERRY SNOW CONES.
HOW MUCH ALCOHOL
IS IN HERE?
11.1%.
WHAT?!
YES.
Corcoran: WOW.
LORI, CHEERS.
ONLY 120 CALORIES
PER SERVING.
WHOO!
AND ONLY 7 GRAMS OF SUGAR
PER SERVING.
Herjavec: YOU KNOW WHAT?
I LOVE THE WINE.
KEVIN, GIVE THEM THE MONEY.
O'Leary:
NO, BUT LET'S...
TELL US MORE
ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
SEE, HE'S THE PARTY POOPER.
WHERE IS IT MANUFACTURED?
WHAT ARE YOUR MARGINS?
WHO'S ACTUALLY
DISTRIBUTING IT?
SO, WE SELF-DISTRIBUTE IT.
WE ACTUALLY BECAME
A WINERY OURSELVES.
AS A TEXAS WINERY,
YOU CAN SELF-DISTRIBUTE IT.
BUT WE GOT, YOU KNOW,
TO THE POINT
WHERE WE WERE SPENDING MORE TIME
IN OUR FACILITY MAKING IT,
GLUING THE BOXES,
AND DISTRIBUTING IT.
WE COULDN'T MARKET IT,
RIGHT?
WE'RE GETTING TOO BIG.
SO WE FOUND A CO-PACKER
IN DALLAS,
AND THEY NOW MAKE IT
FOR US.
WE SIGNED ON
WITH A DISTRIBUTOR.
SINCE THEN, WE'VE GROWN
OUR SALES PRETTY DRAMATICALLY.
Herjavec: WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
SO FAR, JUSTIN?
WE'VE DONE $235,000
IN 14 MONTHS,
AND $120,000 IS COMING
JUST THIS QUARTER.
HOW MUCH MONEY DID YOU RAISE
WHEN YOU STARTED THIS?
SO -- SO, WE SELF-FUNDED IT
FOR $55,000.
WE TOOK ON $100 -- $100,000
IN FAMILY AND FRIENDS' DEBT.
SO TELL ME HOW YOU'RE GONNA GO
FROM $235,000 TO $5 MILLION.
SO, THE STRATEGY IS
TO IDENTIFY NEW STORES
WHERE WE KNOW
IT'S GONNA SELL,
GO INTO THAT STORE,
SUPPORT IT WITH AT LEAST
SIX TASTINGS.
TASTINGS ARE BY FAR
THE BEST WAY
FOR US TO GET
THE PRODUCT OUT THERE.
WHAT DO YOU NEED
THE MONEY FOR?
Fenchel: IT'S FOR THE ENGINE
FOR GROWTH.
OPENING UP NEW STORES
AND, YOU KNOW, SUPPORTING IT
WITH TASTINGS.
OUR TASTINGS COST,
ON AVERAGE...
SO, HIRING THE PEOPLE --
...$100 PER TASTING
IS ON AVERAGE INTO --
THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
IT IS.
DOING IT IN THE STORES
SOUNDS REALLY, REALLY GOOD,
BUT IT'S REALLY HARD
TO LEVERAGE.
ONE STORE AT A TIME,
EVEN WITH BRAND AMBASSADORS,
YOUR LEVERAGE POINTS
PER ANY ONE STORE AREN'T GREAT.
IN MY MIND,
THE STRATEGY WAS WRONG.
YOU KNOW, YOU NEED TO --
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF EVENTS,
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF BIG,
YOU KNOW, PLACES
WHERE THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE.
FEEL LIKE WE'VE ELIMINATED
A LOT OF THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH A NEW
CONSUMER-PRODUCTS COMPANY
IN THIS SPACE.
WE'VE GOT OUTSOURCE
MANUFACTURING,
WE'VE GOT THE LARGEST
DISTRIBUTOR IN THE STATES,
AND WE NEED SOMEONE TO
HELP US SCALE THIS BUSINESS.
THE GOOD NEWS FOR YOU GUYS
IS THERE -- THERE'S --
THERE'S EXAMPLES OF BEVERAGES
THAT HAVE GONE VIRAL
AND GONE NATIONAL.
YOU REMEMBER SKINNY --
THE SKINNYGIRL STORY?
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT WAS THE SAME THING --
VERY VIRAL --
FROM ONE LOCATION.
THEN NEW YORK, FLORIDA,
TEXAS, CALIFORNIA.
BUT SHE RAN LIKE HELL
FOR EVERYWHERE ELSE.
YEAH.
THE -- THE PATH
OF LEAST RESISTANCE
IS CONVERTING THAT PERSON
THAT'S BUYING THAT BOX OF WINE
FOR A PARTY,
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW WHY
THEY'RE BUYING IT.
Herjavec: RIGHT. YEAH.
THAT'S THE EASIEST
CONVERSION.
AND SO, FRANZIA --
AN EXAMPLE --
IS THE NUMBER-ONE BOX WINE
IN THE WORLD,
NUMBER-ONE BY VOLUME.
A BILLION DOLLARS
IN SALES.
FRANZIA DOES $1 BILLION.
IT IS 3% --
WHAT?!
BUT YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT
100% PENETRATION
AND DISTRIBUTION,
AND EVERYBODY'S TRIED
TO KNOCK IT OFF.
I'M IN THE WINE BUSINESS.
I SELL 50,000 CASES A YEAR,
$2.6 MILLION THIS YEAR.
TOOK ME THREE YEARS
TO GET THERE,
AND THE THING
THAT'S HOLDING ME BACK --
YOU FORGOT -- I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT'S HOLDING YOU BACK --
THE NAME.
IT'S CALLED "O'LEARY WINE."
THAT'S WHY IT SELLS.
YOU GOT TO
CALL IT BeatBox.
YEAH.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'D LIKE TO OFFER YOU $400,000
FOR 20%.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
$400,000 FOR 20%,
BARBARA?
YES.
GUYS, THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
IS BREAKING THOSE STATES
THROUGH THEIR
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM.
AND -- AND YOU COULD CERTAINLY
HELP WITH THAT.
NO, DEFINITELY.
OR THE BLUE STATES.
BUT I'LL PUT MY OFFER
ON THE TABLE.
WITH MY OWN EXPERIENCE,
I THINK I'M WORTH TWICE AS MUCH
AS BARBARA.
I'M SORRY.
HOW LOVELY.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
SHE'S DOING IN THIS SPACE.
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000
FOR 20%,
'CAUSE I THINK THE BUSINESS
IS WORTH A MILLION BUCKS
RIGHT NOW.
$200,000 -- SO YOU'RE CUTTING
BARBARA'S OFFER IN HALF.
YEAH.
NOW, THEY COULD GO
WITH BARBARA.
BECAUSE YOU MAKE
A SNOOTY WINE
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS.
NO. UNFORTUNATELY, I'VE LIVED
THROUGH DISTRIBUTION.
THAT NOT MANY PEOPLE
ARE BUYING.
IT'S TOUGH.
WE'RE GONNA DO 22,000 CASES,
9-LITER CASES, THIS YEAR.
MARK?
WHAT?
WHAT UP?
[ CHUCKLES ]
"WHAT UP?"
HOMEY.
I DON'T SEE THIS
AS A WINE PRODUCT.
YOU GUYS GOT THAT DOWN,
RIGHT?
YOU GUYS DON'T SELL WINE.
RIGHT.
PERIOD. END OF STORY.
YOU GUYS SELL FUN.
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT. YOU GOT IT.
AND THE BIGGEST
QUESTION IS,
HOW DO YOU CONNECT
WITH ENOUGH PEOPLE
QUICKLY ENOUGH TO MAKE IT
GROW FAST ENOUGH
THAT, ALL OF A SUDDEN,
YOU'RE GOING,
"WHAT AM I GONNA DO NOW?"
RIGHT?
'CAUSE Y-YOU'RE GOING AS FAST
AS YOU CAN.
YOU NEED A LOT OF HELP.
YOU WANT TO CREATE AS BIG
A SPLASH AS POSSIBLE,
AND I THINK I'M BEST SUITED
UP HERE TO DO IT.
SO WHAT I WANT TO DO IS MAKE YOU
AN OFFER OF 600K...
FOR 33%.
YOU GUYS GOT TO MAKE A DECISION
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
Narrator:
ALL SHARKS ARE STILL IN.
BeatBox BEVERAGES HAS THREE
OFFERS ON THE TABLE --
$400,000 FOR 20% FROM BARBARA,
$200,000 FOR 20% FROM KEVIN,
AND $600,000
FOR 33% FROM MARK.
BUT LORI AND ROBERT
MAY ALSO BE INTERESTED.
I THINK YOU'VE TO BLAST OFF,
YOU'VE GOT TO GO FAST.
THE LAST THING YOU WANT
IS NOT BEING ABLE TO DELIVER,
'CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
VIRAL IS JUST THAT, RIGHT?
AND EITHER YOU'RE THERE
TO FULFILL...
Schultz: YEAH.
...OR YOU LOSE
AN OPPORTUNITY.
Schultz: I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
SAYING THAT AND THAT OFFER,
YOU KNOW,
THANK YOU FOR MAKING IT.
WE -- WE DIDN'T ANTICIPATE
GIVING UP, YOU KNOW --
YOU GOT A COUNTER,
JUST COME BACK AND TELL ME.
YEAH, SO, WOULD YOU DO
$1 MILLION FOR A THIRD?
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
DEAL?
YOU READY?
[ CHUCKLES ]
WOW!
[ LAUGHTER ]
CONGRATULATIONS.
LET'S PARTY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LET'S DO WORK, BABY.
THAT'S A $3 MIL VALUATION.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
I'LL BE IN TOUCH REAL SOON,
AND WE'LL GET IT TURNED AROUND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT,
HE'S GONNA MAKE MONEY ON IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRATS, GUYS.
AND THOSE ARE ALL MINE.
DON'T TAKE THEM.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE WERE GONNA MAKE AN OFFER,
BUT --
I KNEW YOU WERE.
YEAH, WELL, IT WASN'T GONNA
COME NEAR THAT THING.
AAH!
WHOO!
DID THAT REALLY JUST HAPPEN?
OH, MY GOD!
WOULD I HAVE EVER IMAGINED
THAT WE'D BE DOING A MILLION
DOLLAR DEAL WITH MARK CUBAN?
NO.
BUT HERE WE ARE.
WE'VE DONE IT.
AND, UH, HOLY COW.
TIME TO GET TO WORK.
YEAH.
I'M JEALOUS OF THE DEAL.
LET'S PARTY!
[ LAUGHTER ]